ceasefires and safety zones in Eid Lib
have a different meaning to the rest of
the world there is no safe place in
Italy anymore
there is no ceasefire the cries of the
children can be heard long before the
rescuers reached them that wailing is
them their faces are ghostly white with
dust and there's a baby too young to
walk they smeared with blood terrified
and all alone three siblings who'd been
here three days after fleeing from
Saraqeb and Assad's army the Syrian
regime attacks are relentless
hitting areas crammed with civilians who
now have nowhere else to run to
outsiders cannot get into the city
easily so our Syrian camera crews
insided live filmed this for us he's a
father and he's just realized his son as
amongst the dead but the world's not
listening to the weeping by the people
of Italy they gather those killed but
they are barely recognizable anymore as
humans the pain in this city is
everywhere and more than half of the
dead in this volley of strikes are
children those Bashar al-assad is
insisting on terrorists and jihadists
they run because they fear another
attack by the regime with the help of
their allies Russia and Iran the regime
is advancing at lightning speed across
Italy province prompting a mass movement
of people who are heading the only way
they can even closer to the Turkish
border and now turkey's upped the stakes
considerably shifting military hardware
and troops across the border the Turkish
president said he won't stand by as his
soldiers and civilians are killed in
what is meant to be a ceasefire as of
today in the event of even the smallest
injury to our soldiers I announced that
we will strike regime forces everywhere
without being limited to it'd Lib or the
boundaries of the ceasefire agreement
hundreds of miles east along the border
in North Syria American troops come
under fire
look at these flags Russian Syrian
government American a sign of just how
complicated the patchwork of rival
interests is in Syria right now
and how more dangerous it gets by the
day
Alex Crawford Sky News